it was a family reunion for the shit's
creek cast at the 2021 emmy awards
what is your favorite season
awards
eugene levy dan levy catherine o'hara
and annie murphy all returned to present
awards on sunday
the cast looked fabulous on the red
carpet eugene kept it classic with a
black suit while his three co-stars
opted for bold colors with dan in bright
blue catherine and salmon and annie and
teal
i personally would not have missed this
for the whole wide world the beloved
cast received a standing ovation while
stepping on the emmy stage but they had
a little tech mishap
there's nothing on the prompter
so is there like a tech guy or something
um
maybe but we should just open the
envelope i don't think we should just no
no
no it's got to be coming up
the teleprompter never came up but
eugene well he had a little confession
i may have
passed the writer's run this morning and
asked them to
lift the dialogue a little bit but
that's
you casually told a room of comedy
writers to lift your dialogue
all jokes aside fans were excited to see
the rose family back together again
after ending their sixth and final
season last year
and if you remember schitt's creek swept
the 2020 emmys winning a record-breaking
nine total awards what an
absolutely unbelievable way to end our
series i don't think you could ever ask
for a better conclusion to a story than
than tonight so
we are absolutely thrilled but it might
not be the last we see of the roses this
is what dan teased to etie last year
does this mean that there will be some
kind of return or maybe a movie i would
absolutely love to continue telling
these stories it's been the greatest
pleasure and the greatest gift
but back to this year's emmys the shit's
creek cast presented two awards
outstanding writing for a comedy series
and best comedy directing they passed
the comedy torch to hbo max's hacks with
a two back-to-back wins the queen of sin
city miss stepper vance young you guys
are gonna have a fabulous time
2 500 shows what do you have to say well
i'll tell you what i have to say eat
your heart outside we also you know
wanted to make a show that honors
anybody who struggled to tell their
stories especially
women who never got to tell their story
at all because the world wasn't
listening in hack star jean smart took
home the award for outstanding lead
actress in a comedy for her role as the
aging las vegas stand-up performer debra
vance you know when you do something
that is that is uh
meant to entertain that's what you live
for is you know how you're affecting
people
and that is something gene echoed to e.t
in april this ticked every box i mean if
someone had said
okay now at this stage of the game
write down your ideal situation for
a show it had everything
um it was just the character the writing
just everything about it i mean i just
thought it was so unique and so original
and so funny and very moving and
i'm home every night for dinner
[Music]
you